the jurogan experience you know i think
one thing that young boys and and men
as well need in this world is guidance
and mentorship and uh to get that from
martial arts is
one of the best ways and one of the most
uh one of the most fulfilling and
satisfying ways so
i i found you from a video that a bunch
of people sent me
of you uh working with a young boy who
was
having a hard time uh dealing with the
pain of like punching through a board
you know the video and just the way you
were communicating with him and letting
him know that it's okay to cry
and that you know just express yourself
and it was refreshing and it was
authentic but it was also like you could
tell like that kid is going to get a lot
out of that exchange
and i was like i want to meet that guy
well yeah man i mean that video
opened my mind up to really what men
were dealing with
inside because when that video went
viral
our offices that our nonprofit had to
shut down right okay so the cave of
adullum the martial arts program you're
speaking of
is under the umbrella of our non-profit
the union and so when this video went
viral my wife calls me who was our
executive director
she says jason is there a video that's
going viral and i'm like
what do you mean 2016 i didn't really
understand the terminology
and sure enough this video started
racking up a lot of views
shortly thereafter our phones wouldn't
stop ringing and it was men from
all over the world crying to our staff
calling and crying saying i want to be
free i'm tired of holding all of this in
i wish my coach would have talked to me
that way when i was going through yeah
that's it
well it's it's hard to find
a good mentor and i think every man
needs a mentor and you know one of the
things that martial arts does that i
think is
really important is it gives you these
goals to work towards
as you move through a belt system or
whatever kind of
system that each martial art that's
different has
as you develop your skills and you you
get more proficient and you improve you
you
have like tangible progress and you can
see it
and i think there's a lot of people that
go through life not exactly
sure where they stand where they're at
and i think
martial arts provides you with real
feedback
in one of the most i think one of the
most emotionally
and physically difficult things that a
person can do yes and so many people
don't realize the young boy in that
video
bruce he was actually had a fear of
failure he had broke that board
easily the week prior but because of
this test and the pressure and everyone
watching
he just froze on his non-dominant hand
and he couldn't break through
so he broke down crying and i welcomed
his tears and said look we cry as men
you know let this go
and men and i love about martial arts
more than sports
it makes you face your fears and nothing
like a punch is coming at you a kick or
if you're grappling and you're concerned
that someone's going to take your back
and choke you
i apply all these principles in life as
well and so when you give a man or a
male a safe space
to really be emotional and let go of the
anxiety that he feels every day the
father wound
his fear of failure his lack of
confidence where he can
have a moment we call it a moment on the
mat where you can stop
the training and you can express what's
overwhelming you in that moment
they transform instantly man and it's a
it's a great thing to see
and i've never seen anything work like
the arts even with my son
he's 13 years old you saw him you know
six one and a half
everyone says you're gonna play
basketball and it's like no it's other
things that i want to do
and so even with sports i say son it'll
give you some confidence
but when we spar we're training the
anxiety he feels the voices
oh man uh chris hit you again what are
you gonna do about that how are you
gonna maneuver how you're gonna respond
and i allow him to break down in that
moment i said okay cool
now it's time to recover reflect on it
what's the lie what's the truth do you
think this man is not supposed to hit
you he's a skilled fighter
the goal is not for you to be the best
the goal is for you to learn
all right so when i give them that
freedom to feel
to feel the fear now they're not they
don't succumb to it when it really
happens in real life and so
that's why i love the arts especially
the grappling arts which i hate
i didn't discover until later in my
training because
nothing like someone invading your space
you know we can keep distance striking
and we're comfortable here
but when someone invades your space or
when a problem happens in your life
where it's so close and personal
that you can't just shake it you have to
learn how to buy your time and maneuver
and don't let it
come around you or you can get tapped
out by the stress of that situation
the arts is just amazing if it's taught
in a way that men could apply it to life
how long how many years have you been
mentoring young boys
i would say almost 16 17 years and how
did it get started
um in 2000 well i founded our non-profit
in 2003
and from there my father wasn't actively
in my life you know he was around but
wasn't there and i had what's called a
father wound
and basically just an absence of a male
figure in my life specifically my father
he was verbally abusive you know i could
make if i knocked this cup over i would
get cursed out you know things like that
so i had to overcome a lot of that
so in detroit i saw a great need
for uh black boys to be mentored and so
at first i started the cave of adeline
with just martial arts
but then i quickly discovered after
these boot camps
boot camp programs kept failing over and
over again and scared straight programs
was that our boys didn't need more
discipline they needed more love
so then i made the cave of adults more
comprehensive so i still use the arts
focus on what works but also give boys a
safe space to release
the trauma they're dealing with in their
lives the emotional pain the lack of
confidence
all these other things that they're
dealing with and give them this space
where they can release it and become
strong
so that started i had my first pilot in
2008
and then after that 2013 i was awarded a
grant for
just developing the cave and that's when
we just started going full time in our
own location
and we haven't looked back then we have
almost 500 boys on our waiting list
wow yeah and um you know what was
interesting
joe i i thought it was just a black
thing you know because again if that's
all you're around you think that's the
only
youth that are dealing with these issues
i had a group one time it was
multicultural which was great was my
first time
and i saw white kids you know that i i
cared about were struggling so much and
weren't used to releasing what they felt
and one of them uh direct messaged me a
16 year old
he says mr wilson please don't ever
forget about us because he was concerned
because
it was a lot of school shootings at the
time he says
a lot of times we're abused and we don't
know how to process this emotion then
we'll grab a gun and it's the only way
we know how to express
ourselves it's no different from a man
who was volatile and abusive to his wife
you know i used to hit things in my home
joe i'm not
you know proud of saying it you know my
wife would say things that would trigger
me
and i would knock holes in the wall just
in anger because i didn't know how to
express hurt
or sadness or just feeling dismissed and
passively dismissed for how i felt
and as a result i became a very unstable
man mentally emotionally and
i was just what i call just a masculine
male i wasn't comprehensive at the time
and so i've saw a direct correlation
when i allow
a male that freedom to feel
to be angry when you're upset but then
teach you how to reset from that anger
how to use that anger for good because
anger isn't bad
it's only bad when it come you allow it
to make you do bad things
the greatest statistic i love in our
academy is that over
78 percent of our recruits improve their
grade point average by one letter grade
without tutoring
that's because we allow them to be who
they are inside allow them to live from
the good in their heart allow them to
talk about
the things they're experiencing at home
the things they're experiencing at
school we don't just go into training
in martial arts because then they could
be great that day in training physically
believe they're still mentally
traumatized or emotionally damaged
and so the cave is just that it's a
it's a it's an institute or an academy
where we allow boys to feel
you know our mission is to teach train
and transform boys into comprehensive
men men who are physically conscious
mentally astute but spiritually strong
enough to navigate through the pressures
of this world
without succumbing to their negative
emotions so when you're doing this
you're you're learning yourself and
you're also teaching
these kids so how much of a process was
it to develop the curriculum to develop
this program and to figure out what is
the best way
to address these these boys and their
insecurities and their issues and
how to how to give them give them
strength and give them love
but also give them discipline also teach
them how to
how to get through work through pain
work through emotions
it must have been oh man a lot of trial
and error it was a lot of trial and
error
um more so joe i had to
become transparent um in that moment
when that video went viral none of my
recruits really ever seen me cry
you know i was still just tough man and
at the time my mother was going through
dementia
so i'm still trying to develop this
curriculum i'm saying okay it's coming
along but it's still missing something
and what it was missing was giving men
the freedom to be vulnerable
in any given moment and for them to feel
that liberating power
when my mother developed dementia joe um
she was like my sensei man meaning
the emotions that i could hide in
martial arts training because where i
came up
you couldn't express that you know they
would you know once
school i was at they would just rush you
the instructor would say everyone on
jason
and you know we would shake going into
this school our hands were shake cause
it wasn't just grappling
we dealt with real knives you getting
kicked no pads none of that man
but you dealt with real knives yeah so
you're doing like knife
yes because this whole thing is like
everything he's a masterful teacher
a lot of this stuff is choreography okay
you see some of the gun defenses and
things like that it's like come on man
that wouldn't work
right the way he taught us is like if
someone has a knife if you can get away
and go
oh i think jocko said the same thing if
someone has a knife go the other
direction
but if you have to defend yourself first
thing you need to realize is that they
should cut you
if it's just your uncle drunk at a
barbecue they should cut you
can you deal with that pain and that
emotion seeing your own blood run down
your arm and still eliminate the threat
so these things we would practice with
knives because he says if it's plastic
in your head
what happens when a real one comes but
i couldn't express really who what was
going on inside of me that would make me
feel the fear you know the cave needed
that element it needed to say
why are you pulling back why aren't you
applying that armbar why are you scared
to get thrown when your partner needs
you to practice his own and we tie the
throws especially judo throws
to a fear of failure because as you know
in judo
if you're not relaxed when you take that
fall it hurts
significantly more in life if you don't
just go with it and allow yourself the
freedom to make a mistake or freedom to
fall or freedom to fail
when you hit that ground when you fail
to hit that wall it hurts that much more
and so what i had to do was first allow
my students to see
what hurts me my mother had a stroke one
day
and my wife comes in and said hey you
need to leave immediately
your mom has had to get rushed to the
hospital i start breaking down
and all of my kids imagine all of them
in the father's day
surround you hug you and pray over you
just just hugging me
and at that moment i said this is what
they need
they need to see a comprehensive man
someone who's strong but sensitive
someone who's courageous but
compassionate someone who freely lives
from the good in their heart
and doesn't allow their fears to stop
them from living
when that happened joe these boys became
not only greater at martial arts but
greater sons
greater community servants greater
students
able to deal with bullies one of my
students a beautiful kid josiah
short curly hair beautiful personality
he was getting bullied at school but he
thought it wasn't
christ-like you know or the christian
thing to do was to defend yourself you
know you're supposed to take it i'm like
i don't know where you got that from
i said if someone is trying to harm you
defend yourself
so the bully grabs him one day oh gosh
he grabs from behind he throws them
kicked the legs out
and slammed the bully down to the ground
you would think he would celebrate just
defending himself but what made josiah
the proudest was that before the bully
hit the ground
he pulled up on his hoodie to stop his
hair from hitting the cement
hmm wow that's when i knew
i said this is it where the good kids
the gentlemen the kids who are bullied
and overlooked can defend themselves
turn on the lion
but reset back to the lamb no one wants
to be
prowling all around defending and
looking rough all the time having the
hit
and being just in that fight or flight
mode 24 7.
someone tries to harm you you defend
yourself demonstrably
but you reset you don't ever allow your
kind spirit
to conform to something that's callous
and so that's the main
principle that we teach is do not live
from your fears
live from the good that's inside of you
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify